Ah,
I want to emphasize once again,
I said this,
but I would like you to hear me in the end and convey this to your readers,
viewers and users on the Internet.
Well,
you understand or not that if Ukraine will be in NATO and militarily
will return itself to the Crimea,
European countries will automatically be drawn
into a military conflict with Russia.
Of course.
So, the potential,
the united organization of the United States and Russia is not comparable.
We understand.
But we even understand that Russia is one of the leading nuclear powers,
and in some components even ahead of many.
There will be no winners,
and you will be drawn into this conflict against your will.
And you won't even have time to blink an eye when
you fulfill clause 5 of the Treaty of Rome.
Mr. President,
of course,
does not want this development.
And I do not want.
And I don't want to.
That is why he is here and.
And torments me.